بعد 12 يوما على الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا ما تزال الامال قائمه اذا في
العثور على ناجينه تحت الانقاض وفي احدث
احصائيه للضحايا اعلنت السلطات التركيه
ارتفاع عدد القتلى ليتجاوز 38 الفا بينما
تجاوز عدد المصابين 108 الاف شخص كماده
الزلزال الى تضرر اكثر من اربعه وثمانين
الف منزل في المناطق المنكوبه
وفي سوريا بلغ عدد قتل زلزال
شخصا بينما ارتفع عدد المصابين الى اكثر
من عشره الاف وخمسمائه
هذا وقالت وحده تنسيق الدعم التابعه
لائتلاف السوري المعارض من اكثر من 55 الف
شخص نجحوا اللاجئ بعد زلزال يضاف الى نحو
20,000 اخرين كانوا يقيمون في الملاجئ قبل
زلزال
وقد تحول العديد من الساحات العامه وحقول
زيتون في مناطق الشمال الى ما يشبه الماوى
المؤقت لعشرات الالاف من الاسره التي
شردها زلزال هناك
وتقول منظمات منظمات دوليه ان توفير مياه
للشرب وخدمات صرف صحي اصبح امرا ضروريا
لمنع انتشار الامراض